march
2019 we focus the xmm
newton space telescope on a region of
space
around sagittarius a-star
the supermassive black hole at the heart
of our galaxy
[Music]
we spot two huge columns of gas
glowing in x-ray light
the columns seem to be coming from
sagittarius a star
we see giant fountains of gas extending
outward
from the central region as though it's
like a wind or a giant expulsion event
the fountains of gas extend 500 light
years
above and below the supermassive black
hole
that's over a million times the distance
from the sun
to neptune
it looks like this material is actually
leaving the vicinity of the black hole
like it's burping out these giant hot
x-ray
chimneys so why is sagittarius a star
burping out hot gas
typically around a black hole you have
an accretion disk funneling material
into the black hole but all of it
doesn't end up in the black hole
there is a little bit of gas falling
onto it right now even as i'm speaking
right as gas
falls toward the supermassive black hole
it becomes superheated
it liberates an enormous amount of
energy and that energy has to go
somewhere
as gas spirals towards the black hole
some of the material accelerates to near
the speed of light
it blasts out from the accretion disk
creating chimneys of superheated gas
that seemed to connect to two of the
largest structures in the galaxy
the milky way's fermi bubbles
a few years ago we noticed that in fact
there are these giant
bubbles coming out of the very heart of
the milky way galaxy
in each direction there's a bubble 25
000 light years long
but the gas-filled bubbles dwarf the
chimneys of superheated gas
scientists wonder if another more
powerful force
blew the bubbles so what could have
created all of this superheated gas that
actually blew these tremendously large
bubbles
supermassive black holes in other
galaxies
might offer clues black holes at the
centers of galaxies go through different
phases so they can be either active or
they can be calm
sometimes black holes at the centers of
galaxies go through an active
phase and when that happens the black
hole is actively feeding on material
around it which means it's growing
and it also gives off huge jets of
radiation
calm supermassive black holes release a
trickle
of hot gas
but when lots of material falls on them
they can shoot out jets up to millions
of light years long
at the current time sagittarius a-star
is what we call quiescent
it's quiet there is some material
swirling around it
but really not very much but we don't
think that's always been the case
the centers of galaxies are busy places
there are stars there
there's gas there there's dust there and
sometimes these things
fall into that black hole
six million years ago sagittarius a star
may have had a feeding frenzy
eating too much and blasting out the
remains
in huge jets
those jets plow through the galaxy
initially at near the speed of light
and as they do so they can wreak havoc
or sculpt the evolution
of the galaxy that they're propagating
through
sagittarius a-stars jets blasted gas
out of the galaxy creating the scars
we see as the fermi bubbles
now whatever caused those jets seems to
have turned off
it's not happening anymore and we're
seeing sort of the leftovers of them
[Music]
but this is clearly a sign that sometime
in the past few million years
the black hole in the center of our
galaxy sagittarius a-star
was actively feeding on material around
it
material was falling into it and
blasting out this stuff
the jets left destruction in their wake
they may have also affected the growth
of our entire galaxy
these structures at the center of our
galaxy are important because they can
either shut off star formation
or they can trigger star formation
as those jets propagate through the
galaxy they pile up gas
and that gas can be then triggered into
star formation
but these jets can also impart so much
heat
or energy feedback into the environment
that they prevent star formation
so black holes in many ways conduct an
orchestra instructing
or dictating when stars can and cannot
[Music]
form
in the center of the milky way star
formation rates
seem low
the jets could be responsible
but in 2017 the alma telescope
discovered
the change is coming
so alma's actually been able to peer
into the heart
of our galaxy and see that near all this
destruction
there might actually be a new generation
of stars forming
today our calm supermassive black hole
could be helping star formation in the
core
but the fermi bubbles could be evidence
of a time
when sagittarius a-star shut down star
formation
could the supermassive black hole roar
back to life in the future
saggy star could roar back to life by
just dumping some gas onto it
and there's a lot of gas at the center
of our galaxy and it could wander into
the proximity of sagittarius a star
and ultimately fall onto the event
horizon and that would light it up
if sagittarius a-star eats enough gas
it could shut down star formation in the
galaxy for millions of years
it could also give off x-rays and gamma
rays
that may hit the earth
thankfully our central supermassive
black hole
is pretty quiet and massive feeding
events massive energy events
are very very rare
we don't necessarily have much to worry
about
sagittarius a-star has reshaped our
galaxy
if we want to survive in the universe we
need to know
more about this monster black hole
[Music]
the event horizon telescope is on a
mission to do just that
question is can it succeed